[Musique]
bonjour invités de la grande interview
le gynécologue congolais denis mukwege
prix nobel de la paix 2010 8 il préside
est la riposte contre la pandémie de
coronavirus dans le sud kivu sa province
d'origine
en république démocratique du congo
bonjour docteur rukunghu et merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation alors
on vous retrouve à l'hôpital de panzi à
bukavu
dites nous combien de malades vous y
soigner combien de cas graves en
réanimation et de quels moyens vous
disposez sur place bonjour madame je
dois dire qu'au sud kivu peut-être il
faut commencer par donner la situation
aujourd'hui rend compte seulement quatre
malades dans trois guéri et qui on lit
tout simplement des traitements
symptomatiques et nous avons un cas qui
est suivi un isolement
donc pour l'instant ne vont pas encore
eu des cas qui nécessitent une prise en
charge en réanimation
est-ce que vous disposez de moyens en
effet suffisant pour mener à bien la
lutte contre le colis de 19 dans votre
région
l'os piano avion on nous a demandé de
présider l'ue comme la commission santé
de la riposte la pandémie et nous avions
pris une série des mesures et ces
mesures portent surtout sur la
prévention est donc ces six grands axes
de prévention que nous avions pu mettre
en place et il ya deux qui nécessite
absolument que nous ayons la possibilité
de faire des tests pour pouvoir isoler
tous les malades qu'ovide positif et
faire les suivis des leurs contacts à
qui alerte ou lorsqu'ils présentent des
symptômes on peut les tester et les
isoler mais le grand problème que nous
avons par rapport à cette prise en
charge c'est que nous n'avons pas
détester nous pensons que aujourd'hui
c'est le moment d'utiliser les tests et
puisque
après s'il ya une flambée de malades ça
sera impossible on n'aura pas pour biens
matériels de pouvoir faire les tests vu
la fragilité de notre système de notre
système de santé est donc le grand texte
pour nous c'est la prévention est
vraiment la pression
j'ai donc la fragilité de notre système
sanitaire et pivi notre économie on ne
sera pas en mesure de faire des tests
des masses ou faire des tests si il ya
un grand nombre des malades qui viennent
avec des symptômes donc le deuxième axe
c'est la sympathique et ici nous avons
deux hôpitaux qui ont la capacité de
faire don de faire une oxygénothérapie a
pas spécialement
nous avons trois unités pour faire
l'oxygène à l'oxygénothérapie un pas des
lunettes pour des malades aimant grave
et puis on te donner l'oxygène par des
masques et donc ça c'est des
ventilations non invasif et nous avons à
peu près 20 respirateurs pour pouvoir
donner donc le la ventilation invasives
en faisant une intubation voilà le moins
que nous disposons et 20 respirateur
vous pourrez comprendre que ce n'est pas
énorme et donc la chose qu'il faut faire
aujourd'hui c'est faire la prévention
pour éviter qu'elles nous soyons débordé
avec notre capacité limitée en
réanimation
alors c'est vrai que c'est très peu en
termes de moyens mais vous l'avez décrit
de cette situation en rdc dans le sud
kivu il ya très peu de cas 2,2 de décès
comptabilisés
l'afrique qui compte 1 % de cas dans le
monde sait très peu comment vous
l'expliquez ce qu'on sous-estiment les
chiffres ou bien cela reflète la réalité
je crois que comme partout au monde les
chiffrer
sans sous-estimer puisque de toute façon
on ne fait pas des dépistages des masses
de dépistage systématique
donc tous les cas qui sont qui sont
assez automatiques ne sont pas testés et
ces chiffres est certainement à
sous-estimé mais je crois que là il ya
une nuance très important à faire même
si le chiffre est sous-estimé mais nous
pouvons constater que dans les hôpitaux
il n'y a pas un affût des malades avec
insuffisance respiratoire ou qui
présentent des symptômes et qui aurait
traîné piste ils n'ont pas été testés
avant d'arriver donc je pense que nous
devons considérer que les chiffres sont
sous-estimés mais nous ne sommes pas
encore au niveau où se trouve par
exemple l'europe ou les états unis
alors ok la stratégie vous avez déployés
dans le sud kivu pour limiter la
propagation du virus vous parie tout à
l'air de la prévention bon jeu que nous
avions déployé une stratégie adaptée à
notre contexte il faut savoir que 90 %
de notre population vit de l'économie
informelle dont il était pratiquement
impossible de faire les copier coller
des mesures de prévention prises en
occident où on a mis en confinement à
tout le monde ici ça serait soumettre la
population un choix difficile
les chanter rester chez soi la maison et
mourir de faim ou alors sortir prendre
les risques de d'être contaminé par une
corde à virus donc au sud kivu
nous avions proposé parce que là le
confinement soit partiel sachant que en
république démocratique du congo
les personnes qui ont plus de soixante
60 ans représentent seulement 4 % de la
population au sud kivu sais c'est à peu
près 320 mille personnes sur une
population de 8 millions donc
on a proposé à ce qu'est le confinement
puisse être sélectif est concerné
seulement des personnes âgées qui sont
des personnes à haut risque de
complications ça c'est la première chose
vient nous avons nous avons pu faire
pour éviter à ces que donc on puisse
mettre la population dans une situation
intenable et donc qui est notre
stratégie pis échoué
la deuxième chose nous à chantier le 4 %
on paie l'isoler et donc on pouvait
demander à la jeunesse de pouvoir
travailler pour nourrir elles les
personnes âgées mais à condition de
respecter toutes les mesures de
prévention spécialement les gestes
barrière la distanciation sociale et
donc lavage des mains kita est ici nous
avons également demandé à ce que ces
personnes âgées ne puisse pas faire donc
traverser des zones à haut risque vers
les zones à bas risque puisque c'est la
façon également de de propager le virus
troisièmement le pouvoir provincial avec
décidé de fermer les frontières permet
les frontières donc la ville comme la
ville de bukavu d'un million cinq cent
mille habitants étaient totalement
fermés et ça ce sont des mesures qui ont
permis sérieusement d'éviter à ce que
nous ayons de contamination des taux de
contamination très élevé vous soigner
des malades contaminés par les
coronavirus à l'hôpital de de penser
mais avec quel traitement est ce que
vous utilisez la chloroquine dans notre
stratégie aujourd'hui les hôpitaux ne
reçoivent que des malades qui sont en
insuffisance respiratoire donc l'hôpital
provincial du sud kivu et l'hôpital de
panzi jusqu'à ces jours n'ont pas encore
utilisé les moyens qu'ils ont pour
soigner les malades
par contre tous les malades les quatre
malades ont été dans le centre
d'isolement et dans ses centres et
d'isolement
on applique donc les traitements
symptomatiques et le protocole national
utilise hydroxy clémentine et
l'azithromycine quels sont les résultats
obtenus avec un usage de litres ont
chloroquine et les titres homicide je
crois être quatre balles à guadalupe pas
dire qu'on a des résultats c'est que
nous avions déjà demandé ailleurs c'est
ces traitements qui a créé des
polémiques devraient normalement être
soumis à des essais cliniques qui
devrait nous permettre d'avoir la
certitude des visages ces protocoles a
été adoptée au niveau national mais
quand on voit la littérature il ya
beaucoup de controverses et je ne vais
pas entrer dans ces polémiques
je pense que la meilleure façon c'est
leur demande d'avoir des essais
cliniques
bien qu'on dit et que les résultats
soient publiés
je crois que là tout le monde serre et
tranquille d'utiliser ces traitements ou
n'est pas l'utiliser alors puisque vous
parlez de polémique a le remède naturel
aussi malgache auquel semble
s'intéresser l'union africaine plusieurs
dirigeants africains également qu'en
pensez vous nous avions eu le protocole
d'essai traitement ou agache et nous
nous avions soumis ces traitements à
notre comité scientifique et donc et à
notre comité éthique etc les protocoles
est à l'étude
nous espérons que notre comité
scientifique pourrait nous dire si ces
remèdes
nous pouvons faire des essais cliniques
a montré tout son savoir sa validité ou
non mais je crois que au sud kivu
nous avons un comité scientifique formé
par
différents scientifiques de la province
et ses protocoles et alerta blue ils
doivent normalement dire hôpitaux si oui
ou non il faut utiliser donc ces
protocoles malgache votre pays a doctor
mongongu et un resto menacées par
l'épidémie d'ebola est-ce que cela
freine ou au contraire renforce les
capacités de lutte et de prévention
je dois dire que l'épidémie d'ebola que
nous en fait nous avions
on devrait normalement déclaré la fin de
cette épidémie au mois d'avril mais il
ya eu quelques cas qui sont sous
contrôle
normalement cette épidémie nous a aidés
en quelque sorte à pouvoir nous
organiser à la lutte contre cette
pandémie à coronavirus puisque la
population était déjà préparé la
population étaient informés et
sensibilisés sur la nuit des épidémies
de ce type
je crois que ça a été un aspect bon ben
je dirais entre guillemets positif
puisque pour sensibiliser la population
ça allait beaucoup plus facilement
puisque on venait de sortir d'une d'une
épidémie d'ebola qui exige également la
distanciation social lavage des mains
qui était donc pour sensibiliser la
population
les informations étaient aller beaucoup
plus vite mais il est certain
aujourd'hui nous souhaitons que les
lesquelles quelqu'un qu'on a à trouver
il ya quelques semaines puisse être
rapidement maîtrisé puisque si on aura
affaire à deux épidémies aussi
dangereuse qui est beau la et
coronavirus ça pourrait être très très
difficile pour faire face et surtout vu
la qualité de nos structures sanitaires
merci beaucoup dr ado ni moko goûts et
pour cette grande interview accordée
rt france merci bon courage à vous dr
bourgault et à toutes vos équipes dans
le sud kivu à l'hôpital de panzi siens
et merci à vous d'avoir suivi cette
grande interview une grande interview
que vous pouvez retrouver sur nos
réseaux sociaux et en podcast sur notre
site internet
rt france point tv à très bientôt
[Musique]
vous
oui
[Musique]